and yan is just threatening to queen the
h pawn so magnus needs to find some cow
to play quickly
against that h pawn five
he's gotta find something or he's just
gonna lose
one okay with two seconds on the clock
okay and that's a silent draw offer from
magnus because now he's trying to get
the black queen across to trek the white
king from behind but if the white king
steps back we've seen that position
before okay jan does not want the draw
playing for the win playing for the win
good man wow and the bar is definitely
live in this game yeah and that check
from the white queen was blocked by
black's knight i'm surprised by that one
black's knight pinning itself and now
the black knight cannot move on this
diagonal but then again white does have
to reply to some threats black's queen
wants to come the whole way across the
board with a check to the white king
that would be really scary also black's
pawn in the center of the board can step
down attacking the white queen
whoa
he blocks this check with his queen and
the white queen now forced to the side
of the board